[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler régis le
sommier grand reporter rt france bonsoir
régis merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
général dominique trinquant expert en
géostratégie ancien chef de la mission
militaire française à l'onu bonsoir
dominique traquant et merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés pour nous accompagner
reza jafari un président de
l'association enfants d'afghanistan
bonsoir reza jafari merci aussi à vous
d'être là régis le sommier la maison
blanche qui dit désormais ne plus avoir
d'autre choix que de discuter avec ses
anciens ennemis en afghanistan ça sonne
comme un nouvel aveu d'échec de
washington je pense que l'échec il a eu
lieu
l'échec il a été sept ce retrait comment
particulièrement périlleux du pays alors
que bon ça s'était déroulé les
américains toute façon avait dit depuis
longtemps qui partait il avait donné une
date butoir au départ du 11 mai qui
avait ensuite repoussé fin août on
connaît on a vu tous ces images qui ont
terni celle de l'amérique
en fait c'est presque les retrouvailles
je dirais à doha puisque les bus ne pas
oublier que les américains pendant
pratiquement 8 ans ont dialogué avec les
talibans justement essayant de jouer
cette carte de l'inclusivité
sexuellement à la main dans ce moment de
dire voilà je prenais voilà comment
essayons essayer de faire 1 1 essayons
puisqu'au départ y avait quand même des
représentants de toutes les parties
d'afghanistan pendant longtemps dans ces
discussions de doha et puis in fine et
les talibans n'ont absolument pas
respecter ce qu'ils avaient dit à part
leur accord avec l'armée américaine
curité voilà d'une qui ont été à part 2
ce traité de paix entre l'armée
américaine et les talibans de qui date
de février 2020 lui a été respectée plus
aucun américain n'a été tué ni blessé
après février 2020 et ensuite la donc
donc ils se retrouvent ils se retrouvent
avec à la clé plusieurs choses et en
particulier la reconnaissance possible
du régime taliban et donc tout est sur
la table là on voit qu'il ya la question
des femmes on voit quelle est la
question du terrorisme la présence
américaine dans la région et je pense
que c'est tout tout ça est en gestation
et à la clé pour les talibans il ya la
reconnaissance de leur régime joe biden
qui explique l'administration que la
realpolitik avait parfois plus forte que
les considérations intérieures vous qui
connaissez justement les arcades
notamment de l'onu ça vous inspire quoi
ces nouveaux pourparlers qui ne sont
effectivement pas pas les premiers mais
enfin on voit qu'entre temps les
promesses n'ont pas été vraiment tenu
notamment sur la composition du
gouvernement oui alors il ya trois types
de pourparlers il ya les américains avec
les talibans à doha c'est la
continuation comme vous le disiez c'est
l'application de l'accord qui a été
signé il ya un an c'est intéressant de
voir que les talibans d'ailleurs refuse
de collaborer avec les américains dans
la lutte contre edf mais disent c'est
notre problème il faut rappeler que
c'est un des volets de l'accord de doha
une deuxième négociation
on a vu monsieur goûter res et les
nations unies avec le conseil des droits
de l'homme qui a nommé un rapporteur
spécial pour s'occuper justement du
problème des des droits de l'homme et en
particulier de la place des femmes vous
rappeler que ce ceci a été proposée par
l'union européenne et donc à vous parler
de l'union européenne qui valait à doha
c'est justement sur ce volet là donc on
voit bien qu'il ya deux volets très
distincts la sécurité globalement c'est
les américains qui s'en occupent les
droits de l'homme globalement c'est les
européens qui s'en occupe par le biais
de l'onu et aussi par le biais de
l'union européenne résa jafari les
droits de l'homme justement vous avez
certainement tant qu'association des
nouvelles du terrain où en est on
justement 31 août deux mois après ce
retrait américain
alors sur le plateau on entend par rza
jafari chef assure longtemps à l'antenne
voilà manifestement un petit problème de
son pardonnez-nous reza jafari on vous
entend pas on va essayer de régler
régler cela voilà réserve safari
apparemment on a rétabli la connexion
avec vous
oui je on parle de droits de l'homme et
ont parlé des talibans les talibans
il ya un mois j'étais en plateau sur
l'autre chaîne et on parlait déjà les
les talibans qui avaient commencé les
tribunaux talibans qui avaient commencé
à donner les ordres l'exécution est
aujourd'hui dans le valais de peinture
on trouve des combes où il ya des
dizaines et des dizaines de personnes
des mains attachées par derrière qui ont
été assassinés par les talibans les
déplacements
obligatoire continue
nettoyage ethnique et nettoyage des
religieuses
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de tech
mais en y avait le gouvernement des
seychelles danny et que la faute était
sur les talibans et aujourd'hui quand il
ya des attentes 1 la faute est sûre
d'aller chez mais ne laissera pas
oublier que tâche et al qaeda et les
talibans
sont les mêmes et aux eaux
lors idéologique c'est de conquérir le
monde et il faut pas s'étonner et que
très bientôt il y aura peut-être même
une alliance et en trio entre les
talibans d'ail hachée et aussi
les
les talibans mais aujourd'hui vous
parler
on va les et humanitaires en parler les
droits de l'homme plus de 90 % des
établissements de santé sont armés
plus de 90 pour soins des populations
pourraient très pauvre en 2022 plus de
90 % n'ont pas assez à manger 5 millions
d'enfants souffrent de malnutrition
18 millions de femmes sont enfermées
chez elles sont privés de tout droit de
leurs droits fondamentaux et côté
plusieurs milliers des élites
intellectuelles ont fui le pays et quel
avenir aura le pays avec en tête les
talibans aux terroristes qui sont petit
à petit en train soit s'allier aux
autres
groupes terroristes
jafari nous parle effectivement de ces
attentats évidemment maintenant qu'ils
sont de signer d'état islamique c'est un
petit peu cocasse cette situation les
talibans passerait presque pour des
enfants de choeur sur place vous y
croyez cette fameuse alliance dont parle
reza jafari et surtout le fait qu'ils
poursuivent le même but donc j'ai là et
l'autre rapidement s'il vous plaît
idéologiquement si vous permettez ils
ont ils ont
les talibans ou
combattues dèche
de façon d'ailleurs très dur notamment
dans les zones de l'est mais pas pour
des raisons idéologiques mais parce
qu'ils ont vu en dèche un groupe
concurrent un groupe rival qui a un
moment lors a pris un certain nombre de
combattants les talibans étant rentrés
justement dans ce processus de
négociations avec l'occident et au
niveau du terrain ils ont recueilli un
certain nombre d'échos en disant voilà
les talibans maintenant ça devient voilà
donc des ch a connu un certain succès
dans les zones du kunar de nangarhar à
l'est dans les ccc season 1 gouvernable
de l'est de l'afghanistan et les
talibans les ont vaincus et ils ont
utilisé cet argument d'ailleurs
vis-à-vis des américains et l'utilisé
encore aujourd'hui en disant qu' ils
vont s'en débrouiller que des ch est
toujours peu vive à ce qu'on a vu il ya
eu notamment la semaine dernière ce
terrible attentat contre une mosquée
chiite dans la ville de koundouz et
qu'il les talibans disent nous on veut
pas pour le moment d'accord sur le
terrorisme je ne crois pas qu'il y aura
un accord entre des chez les talibans en
revanche ce que je sais c'est que les
talibans n'ont jamais
rompu leur bail à c'est à dire lors
lorsque l'allégeance qu'al-qaïda leur a
fait a fait au mollah omar à l'époque où
il était au pouvoir
allianz qui a permis d'ailleurs
d'accueillir ben laden et les siens en
afghanistan avec les conséquences qu'on
connaît et que les talibans n'ont pas
rompu nos pas souhaité rompre cette
alliance donc voilà maintenant dèche
c'est un peu différent des ch vous dis a
été combattue comme un groupe terroriste
et comme un groupe concurrent par les
talibans est aujourd'hui des shs entend
bien déstabiliser les talibans je citais
cet attentat
juste là dessus l'attentât de koundouz a
été perpétré par un combattant de dèche
ouïghours c'est à dire de la minorité
musulmane chinoise de chine on connaît
les relations entre les chinois est ce
que font les chinois ouïghours en ce
moment il y avait un message clair aussi
puisque les chinois eux sont alliés avec
les talibans donc tout ça c'est un jeu
mais en tout cas des chais toujours
présent et pour le moment je vois pas
d'alliance entre des chez les talibans
au contraire
sont des éléments de de négociations je
répète les américains vont négocier sur
la sécurité que les talibans lutte
contre des ch c'est un élément en faveur
des talibans pour la négociation avec
les américains donc c'est un élément de
négociation de même que lorsqu'on parle
des droits de l'homme est évidemment que
tout ce qui se passe là-bas avec les
talibans et est
abominable mais c'est aussi un argument
de négociation avec l'union européenne
je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui en
afghanistan ils n'ont pas le choix tout
est coupé tous les robinets sont fermés
donc s'ils veulent faire venir de l'aide
humanitaire s'ils veulent avoir de
l'argent il va falloir qu'il donne
quelque chose en échange quand on écoute
reza jafari voilà il ya aussi surtout
beaucoup de souffrance humaine sur place
ne surent pas que des négociations entre
grandes puissances à l'onu ya des gens
qui mais si on s'en sort quel avenir
pour ce pays mais justement c'est un
argument de négociation les talibans
avec l'est la situation terrible qui a
là bas disent regardez vous allait
aggraver encore la situation donc donné
nous
l ont été
il ya eu des commandes et projets il
était petit filet et elle et notifie les
fumées attendait c'est l'hiver qui
arrive c'est l'hiver qui arrive donc
c'est une catastrophe humanitaire donc
il faut ré ouvrir tous les robinets et
ce site sur paris ouvert on commence les
négociations et naturellement les
talibans comme sur la sécurité négocier
avec les américains la prise en compte
de dèche avec les européens et l'onu ils
vont négocier les droits de l'homme et
une certaine un certain assouplissement
on verra les tout le monde dira on aime
bien les discours mais on veut voir les
acteurs on va voir les actes en échange
d'une aide humanitaire massive parce
qu'il faut une aide humanitaire massive
évidemment de cynisme on imagine pour
vous dans cette affaire
alors
tout à l'heure juste pour terminer
aujourd'hui dans le nord d'afghanistan
il ya quelques jours on avait une
discussion
deich est en train d'armer 1 ceux qui
veulent combattre les talibans et tout à
l'heure vous avez parlé ligoure
ici ont utilisé aussi par tech pourquoi
je dis qu il possible alliance est avec
al qaïda et les talibans parce qu'ils
ont les mêmes idéologies et que par par
le passé en afghanistan même s'ils ont
combattu
des chez les talibans ils ont mené des
opérations
ensemble plusieurs fois
notamment lors de les attaquer les
maternités à kaboul d'acheter parti en
vue pour les aides humanitaires ce que
nous en demande et les associations et
les ong on demande à halloween mandanda
internationale de soutenir surtout le
peuple de soutenir les eaux et jean pour
que les et puisse aller directement à la
population n'est pas aux talibans on n'a
aucune garantie que les talibans ont
distribué ces aides et en plus en plus
on négocie avec les éléments plus on
leur donne la légitimité à chaque fois
qu'on a négocié avec les talibans ils
n'ont jamais respecté aucun accord
jamais jamais aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'ils attaquent pas les étrangers en
afghanistan mais il faut savoir qu'il
n'ya pas vraiment l'étranger ou des
forces étrangères en afghanistan n'ont
pas
respecté les accords sinon ils ont
respecté aucun apport est aujourd'hui il
faut pas bientôt demain il y aura une
discussion avec l'europe il répète
encore une fois quand on parle avec les
gens sur place malgré toute cette
souffrance ils ne veulent pas vivre ce
que la reine du les talibans et qu'il
dise plus on nous discuter et négocier
avec les talibans le thunder bay
légimité et on va reconnaissance de
gouvernement des talibans ce qui va être
une vraie catastrophe n'est pas une
catastrophe
vraiment une saveur pardonnez moi je
voulais distribuer un petit peu la
parole vous êtes tous très bavard ça
vous fait plaisir enfin chez obligé de
voilà d'arbitrer un peu
général fera qu'en oui c'est vrai plus
on discute plus on donne de la
légitimité
les états unis demain l'europe après
demain à moscou les humanitaires qu'elle
arrive par le biais des ong moi je veux
bien mais ils négocieront avec les
talibans sans accord avec les talibans
rien n'arrivera et donner l'aide
humanitaire aux angie on connaît le
travail des ong remarquable sur le
terrain mais ils sont obligés de
négocier avec les talibans donc voilà et
il faut négocier des deux côtés de façon
à obtenir des talibans deux des droits
de l'homme et des droits des femmes
surtout en échange on donne de l'aide
humanitaire qu'on va peut-être faire
transiter par les ong mais qui elle
aussi négocieront sur le terrain avec
les talibans il n'y a pas d'autres
moyens non je dis moi si je vais revenir
sur une situation la plus critique en
afghanistan aujourd'hui ces eaux là où
il ya peut-être un levier que la
communauté internationale peut faire
jouer c'est précisément ce qu'on a
décrit mais dans les détails c'est
encore pire que ce qu'on peut imaginer
la situation là il ya une grosse partie
de la population afghane qui à risque de
famine aujourd'hui j'ai eu des nouvelles
du côté de bamiyan notamment où les gens
ont quasiment plus rien à bouffer et que
disons que l'hiver arrive comme on
disait donc là il ya une situation
extrêmement critique et dans les
hôpitaux on le voit aussi dont un homme
n'a vu quand même des quelques images
assez effrayante de nourrissons arrivons
complètement décharné dans certains
endroits et là
les talibans ne peuvent pas se permettre
ils peuvent on sait qu'ils sont capables
d'imposer un ordre on sait qu'ils sont
capables d'imposer leur loi leur charia
et tout ce qui est venu avec mais en
réalité c'était pas dans leur intérêt
d'avoir cette famine qui se déclare et
que la communauté internationale peut
obtenir il sait pas un chantage mais
peut obtenir quand même certains
certains aménagements parce que ils
savent très bien les discussions avec
l'europe les droits de l'homme oui mais
ils savent très bien qu il ya des pays
qui peuvent aidée notamment l'allemagne
et talibans d'ailleurs ont pris contact
directement avec les allemands sans
passer par l'europe donc ils savent que
ici le rôle s'ils veulent s'installer
ils ont attendu vingt ans pour reprendre
le pouvoir ils n'ont pas l'intention de
le quitter or les afghans ce sont des
gens qui peuvent être très versatile il
ya certains il ya une certaine adhésion
d'une certaine partie de la population à
l'idéologie talibane si l'état n'en sont
pas le boulot ils peuvent être aussi
l'objet il peut y avoir des dérives des
révoltes en afghanistan une opposition
qui s'arme des seigneurs de guerre qui
change de camp etc etc c'est toujours
c'est une possibilité donc là il ya un
moment critique et il ya un moment où il
me semble la communauté internationale
peut justement faire changer et
peut-être faire évoluer les choses oui
oui non simplement pour dire les les
talibans au doivent réussir pour eux
mêmes doivent réussir aujourd'hui et
pour réussir les deux les données
viennent d'être exprimées il va falloir
qu'ils cèdent un certain nombre de
choses alors ils essayent de façon
maligne passé par l'allemagne pas passer
par l'europe ça ne marchera pas
l'allemagne restera dans le groupe
européen pour arriver à faire poids face
aux talibans résa jafari quand vous
entendez parce qu'on on parle beaucoup
on n'aura pas évident avant forcément de
nos positions de
massoud du commandant massoud mais il ya
une partie aussi de la population qui
adhère aux talibans à ce que ça vous le
vous le constaterez tout de même vous
aussi avec les nouvelles que vous avez
du terrain
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya une partie de
la population qui adhère j'ai
l'idée régime des talibans parce qu'ils
sont obligés
certaine façon mais aujourd'hui la
plupart des gens qui s'en allait des
nouvelles que nous on a des terrains
aujourd'hui et l'alliance du nord ce
n'est pas qu'aux dans le ballet des
peintures mais aussi un portrait partout
en afghanistan les chefs de guerre de
plus en plus
ce organique les chefs de guerre qui
s'enlise dans les pays est limitrophe et
qui s'organisait tout à leur
poser une fois c'est la chaîne touch est
vraiment toute la population et une fois
collé talibans n'arrive pas vraiment à
diriger le pays et à satisfaire les
besoins de la population
il va et puis avoir soit en soulèvement
national était chaque côté et dans le
diable dans le nord vous avez le fils le
commandant massoud zénith de son côté
aussi général de ce sommet qui était à
un cheveu gars très puissant mais dans
le souci il y à des mouvements de
résistance et qui se créent aussi mais
il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'argent et qui
sont prêts à aider
financièrement ses résistances mais
aussi peut-être autrement
merci en tout cas tous les trois résa
jafari régis le sommier je vais à
dominique tricaud remercier d'avoir été
avec nous